[Music]
all right what's hood y'all welcome back
to another episode of easy to [ __ ]
compassion corner compassion corner we
are taking stories from Reddit reading
them and deciding is this person an
[ __ ] or not so this one is in nosy
[ __ ] News submitted by Bo's Bo's in ten
thank you thank you
keep rolling a little bit of an [ __ ]
am I the [ __ ] for telling the cashier
that that wasn't the girl's credit card
mm-hmm
all right so this one says I was in a
higher-end department store today and
happened to end up next to two teenage
girls while shopping one of the girls
had picked out a very expensive pair of
boots and they were both fawning over
them the second girl must have looked at
the price tag and asked boots girl if
she's really gonna spend that much on
boots girl with the boots says something
along the lines of it's fine I have my
dad's credit card I'm not paying which
instantly caught my attention because
that's not her card it says on all
capital letters I told my son multiple
times he's never allowed to use my card
so I'm introduced ëhow this girl thinks
she's gonna get away with fraud but I
had split up the but had split up from
the girls at this point because they had
found something else we end up at the
same register me behind them and I see
her total hit well over four digits this
ones rang up over a grand this is that
Bloomingdale's
that's easy us one pair of boots are
like for that girl that's true the girl
is about to swipe her card when I
decided that I can't let her get away
with something like this and someone has
to parent this kid if no one else will
tell the cashier that that isn't her
card but her father's and I'm not sure
that she has permission girl and friend
turn and glare at me giving me possibly
the dirtiest look I've ever seen he's
none of your [ __ ] business
I swear this girl was gonna throw a
tantrum right there I don't think she's
ever been told no girl tells her a
cashier that her father gave her the
card to shop with because it's the
stores card and it gives him the points
now that I pointed out that it wasn't
hers the cashier tells her that she
can't use the card girl tries to show ID
to prove that they have the same last
name parentheses yeah that will help in
parentheses and I tell her it's still
fraud people who try to parent other
people's kids
girl says it's not fraud because she has
permission and tells me to mind my own
business I tell her that it is my
business that she's doing something
illegal and she needs to take her own
literally not your business I'll call
the cops
girl is pissed now and everyone's
glaring at me she uses her own card and
leaves crying the cashier looks mad at
me and I tell my husband when I get home
only for having to agree that I was in
the wrong your husband is terrified of
you so reddit miv ass yes exactly
I'm surprised that she didn't get caught
with the card immediately because they
always ask for ID one day hey you know
they just sometimes not always take
you're supposed to policy I said my mom
would give her give me my her card if
she was like it was my birthday and she
had to work or something she'd be like
oh go by yourself sorry I get asked for
ID a lot so I just thought it was you
got one of them things you shaved [ __ ]
was it was it when you were wearing like
your cholos now I didn't have a credit
card back there but right now like
though every time I just bought boots
they're like you have credit whatever yo
Jones over here bringing up
thousand-dollar tabs with a thick ass
gold-plated credit card I'm over here
with my like my Platinum Wells Fargo
starter member card limit credit limited
credit card on the bottom probably like
credit limit said in like Joe's like
know people are carding me Visa IV it
depends on the store because I feel like
stores I have a lot of fraud they ask
for it but like I don't know lady asked
for it cuz the other lady was make such
a big deal yeah because the cashier
didn't want to get in trouble
technically they can't it has to match
the ID yeah it's a but this [ __ ] week
as seeing somebody jaywalking and
flagging down a cop yeah
and holding them there's of the cosmos
is my business that you are crossing the
street or to make a crime
this is citizen's arrest if that
happened if that was my daughter right I
would have wanted her to call me like
what the [ __ ] right right yeah but then
I don't know and that's what makes me go
maybe she wasn't supposed to use Daddy's
card but either way it wasn't that
lady's business yeah no it wasn't her
business but I would still want to be
known so I could [ __ ] say give that
[ __ ] the phone yeah [ __ ] is wrong with
you [ __ ] seven times out of ten times
if it [ __ ] at Bloomingdale's it's
with your daddy's card this is very
common shake a child at Bloomingdale's
right like they can't afford that [ __ ]
yeah daddy was like she's hard yeah cuz
you know dad's gonna still pay for it
yeah yeah and if she did take her dad's
card he's gonna see the charge so if she
wasn't supposed to have the card she's
gonna get a job for it right he's gonna
see the charge so this lady needs to
mind her own [ __ ] business
right well what am the only victim here
is a dad now he doesn't get the points
yeah I will say two though like it's
this [ __ ] was gonna spend $1,000 on
this yeah yeah but what if we guy's a
billionaire dude like you don't know
says she uses it she used her own card
so she did spend it I'm just but he's
gonna he's gonna he's gonna take care of
it right probably yeah I'm just saying I
don't feel as bad that she left crying
and stuff because she's kind of chick
who biased I was all business Oh cuz
she's privileged $5,000 boots if I had
the money originally yeah let me see I'm
telling you when I get rich boom make it
right Schmitt I'm gonna be like Gina and
this [ __ ] to coach bags just
walking down the street like two bags in
a nose job count me in you do this you
won't be rich for longbows I know I will
because the money gonna keep coming
Steve believe it oh really it'll last
forever handsome oh I heard a lot of
youtubers say that [ __ ] to me two pairs
of boots on you know how many to relax
over the other
that's right you know many how many
supers I've known over the years who
bought three million dollar mansions
because they thought this money's going
but they don't for you for Christmas
that's all I ask where was dr. Martin
booth hundred bucks not that yeah one
forty two hundred bucks man that's just
that's one beach why did okay what
happens in an old lady's life that this
kind of stuff starts coming out where
they have to get involved and do this
[ __ ] like is there like something where
they've control issues yeah it's a
control issue right like like barbecue
Becky and like all these other parts of
their lives yeah exactly yeah and born
on mana boredom some of the phrases she
uses she says I'm interested to see how
this girl thinks she's gonna get away
with Freud
she already filled in the backstory yeah
on this girl some crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
insane like she's like this trial maybe
this woman stole credit cards from her
debt and charge it up and now it's like
when cheaters are like you must be
cheating cuz they've done it or maybe
she's like stever she's met at like that
this little girl gets to get $1,000
boots and she had to work away in to
earning that amount of I'm not mad that
she can get them I'm mad that she wants
them that she want because you could for
that but you could spend it does also
much more effective teacher that type of
lesson but like you know society
convinces these girls that they need
external things to feel validated but
what if the boots look dope though yeah
exactly I want girls to have a thousand
dollar boots because it looks so nice
they better light the [ __ ] up put a
grand on it is like it like it's a
difference of comfort shoe though yeah
they better blink every time you take a
step there's some advanced high
technology
got some good technology they used the
Earth's magnetic field to it to hover to
levitate what are the comments like on
this anyone on her side Oh
absolutely no one else they did she
closed her account afterwards
no she didn't she's still kicking in
this [ __ ] flesh she made someone inside
did it ever occur to you that she was
telling the truth
and her dad gave her the credit card
mind your own business someone said mind
your own [ __ ] business that girl's
dad probably makes money and she spoiled
and it absolutely isn't your job to
parent her and embarrass her like that
in a store you also aren't a pet oh my
god yes she was jealous I feel a little
jealous yes young girl - you also aren't
a federal law enforcement officer
investigating did you respond did I wish
she did she's sitting there and she's
like she's like honey I can't talk like
now like I had so many haters yeah yeah
she didn't have a whistle at the
department store but citizens a riot I
feel bad for her husband - my husband
agrees - yeah he probably has to agree
everything or else you're gonna [ __ ]
give them hell he also agreed to
electric nipple clamps yeah and then sit
on the top bunk that day that night oh
you know that he's the same kind of
person and he would do the same exact
thing know that husband said when she
when she got home she told her husband
and it said he agreed that she was in
the wrong oh and the wrong yeah yeah
yeah
he's been agreed agreed - no I read it
as she has in the kid was in the wrong
yes that's what I thought no that
husband okay so the husband's not not
being abused well no he probably is he
scared as [ __ ] of this chick but he let
it burn out honest I think that she came
home and he felt the chill was she's
back that should be shopping for much
longer store word on my side my
husband's not on my side the internet
they'll be on my side that always works
out it is delusional enough to really
tighten this all out and think like
people are gonna take my side well dear
I do I think that you yeah maybe a
little crazy and then she's like all I'm
gonna tell the internet you'll see you
stupid [ __ ] is always like just gonna
play devil's advocate here but guess his
own actual about so vivid to like she
got it clearance day like this was then
not leave out any details so everybody
knows the exact story that went down and
said they'll be all my son she probably
didn't even type this to find out am I
the [ __ ] it was probably look at what
I did because that's crazy if she said
this in a middle-aged mothers Facebook
page it would be completely different
than read it you know ten thousand likes
this is the first this is the person who
leaves a waitress a tip and if they
write on the thing like get a better job
and then they they go home and they're
like yeah I told her to get a better job
and like isn't that great and versus
like no and then they tell the Internet
and get destroyed and a [ __ ] GoFundMe
gets placed against them and the person
raises like 30k to send the waitress on
[ __ ] vacation and this person can't
believe how hard they lost this
interaction
they're in disbelief yeah that's what
the Internet has given us like [ __ ] like
this I love it
public humiliation I just love her
verbage I decide that I can't let her
get away with something like this
encounters so many of these weirdos that
I'm glad like things like this are
happening to them me too because in the
past they didn't have any type of
responsibility for their actions mm-hmm
no before the internet they got away
with this [ __ ] all the time yep
[Music]